[Music]
hi everybody thanks so much for joining
us we begin with sad news here is
tonight's top story
Star Wars icon Carrie Fisher passed away
today at the age of 60 she has suffered
a heart attack on Friday on an airplane
while landing at LAX ad has learned that
she never regained consciousness a
family spokesperson released this
statement today quote it is with a very
deep sadness that Billie lourd confirms
that her beloved mother Carrie Fisher
passed away at 8:55 this morning she was
loved by the world and she will be
missed profoundly Carrie became famous
as the fierce take-charge princess from
the first Star Wars trilogy she was just
21 an instant superstar without giving
you a goodbye kiss I can arrange that
born into the Hollywood spotlight she
was the daughter of singer Eddie Fisher
and actress Debbie Reynolds he first
interview the outspoken actress back in
1981 she was supporting equal rights for
women I'm not worried about losing fans
because your possible fans might not
agree with you my fans are about 9 and
10 and 12 years old I don't think so but
Fame as Princess Leia came at a
consequence the actress wrote about
taking drugs with her father around the
time of 1975 shampoo starring Warren
Beatty cocaine and painkiller abuse were
symptoms of a greater problem Carey had
a chemical imbalance I've been in
therapy since I was 15 years old and
I've had right now I visit with three
different shrinks that was 1999 after a
stint to rehab she was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder when she was 24 around
the same time the Empire Strikes Back
was released I love you
off-camera Kerry was known for having
new filter she recalled doing cocaine on
the set of the sequel and told us about
one of many hospitalizations I I was in
there on a psychotic manic high stayed
awake for five and a half days and I was
put as a result of that on ativan and I
got it
that's a benzodiazepine and that's a
very bad addiction and I was on that
drug for a year and a half under a
doctor's care and when I went to say
okay I would rather not be on this
anymore to get off of that I had to go
into rehab again the combination punch
of drug addiction managed confessions is
bad yeah and I've had some difficult
experiences in relationships she married
singer-songwriter Paul Simon in 1983 the
relationship quickly fell apart
Fischer's second marriage was to talent
agent Brian Lord in 1992 Kerry had her
only child Billie lourd who's also an
actress today and last year fans were
treated to sing her on screen once again
as Princess Leia in the force awakens
and she had already wrapped filming on
Star Wars 8 both movies she made with
her daughter
what's your first Star Wars memory and
then bring it to this moment here with
your mom they'll come in here the first
Star Wars memory was mine memory was Mia
kicking and screaming because she was
begging me to watch it I was like four
years old she put it on beggar and she's
bored you're wrong anyway whatever
so she begged me to watch it I obliged I
sat down what would you even have told
your younger self you know if you could
go back you know I don't think I could
have told my younger self and you know
it's sort of like what I know best um
get help I mean really there's not what
you know it learns to say the words I
don't know mean them do it all I did it
all but and I still did the bad stuff
too but eventually you know it did catch
up and I was able to apply something
you
[Music]